I mean look the thing is this movie is
so much delicious fashion so tell me how
he came up with these looks the inspo is
clear but how did you come up with all
we didn't even talk it's so crazy we
just said let's meet at 7 o'clock on the
carpet and see what happens and surprise
professional weirdo march to the
original angels they all wear the sequin
little jumpsuit so you know we are all
very new hair is very Oh Maj thank you
so much my track name was actually
inspired by Farrah Fawcett so it's
really cool to get to do this yeah you
guys seen the three ladies then I'm
sorry have you seen the three new ladies
yet tonight not tonight tonight but we
did have a chance to shoot a little
promo with them what was it like we were
honoring angels for just a day and it
was life-changing did you give them any
tips for posing and did you give them
drag names of their own I gave them some
nail tips from you know that they could
put on it later and I gave them some
beef tips so it was so much fun doing it
it was so much fun and we are so excited
we what the only thing could have topped
that the expense of shooting was being
invited here to see them again in all of
their glory on the big screen and on the
aubergine carpet and we're living it's
very quickly do you have any drag names
that I could tell them you've given them
later oh my god banks the boss because
seriously like she has been so like
ain't like imperative and making sure
that we had a spot here tonight we don't
know these lovely ladies I think are
nameless I mean they're not nameless but
they don't mean good I mean they don't
necessarily need drag names because the
themes that are in their celebrated in
this film the female empowerment the the
going beyond genders it's a it
transcends drag names and they are just
perfect as they are
period I know you did it there but I'm
gonna get three of you to say good
morning Charlie to camera together
absolutely good morning charlie
[Music]